hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll we talk about science a lot here
at mindscape I don't think anyone uh
could avoid getting that impression but
you know we talk about other things too
I I do try to let people in on the
details the real world details of how
science gets done uh it's not always
straightforward it's a little bit less
it's it's different let's say than the
press release model right like the way
that we learn about science is very
often because some scientists have done
something and then if it's a discovery
experimentally or like a really cool
Theory they will have a press release or
there will be newspaper or internet
articles or whatever or they'll write a
book or have a podcast
Etc that's not really how science gets
done science is much more incremental
it's much more gradual and there's a lot
of tools that people use so today's
subject matter is a little bit different
we're talking about cosmology but we're
talking about specifically the role of
computer simulations in cosmology Our
Guest is Andrew ponson who is a
cosmologist at UC London over there in
the UK he has a new book that just came
out called the universe in a box
simulations and the quest to code the
cosmos and I love the topic because he
talks a lot about the Big Bang cosmology
inflation Dark Matter Etc but the
central organizing principle is how we
use computer simulations to do this kind
of Science and that's both crucially
important because these days you can't
you know the theories are so complicated
that you can't make very good detailed
predictions with a pencil and paper you
really need to use a computer simulation
and because that act which seems kind of
innocent let's just put it on a computer
and simulate it maybe it's not so
innocent after all I mean I don't mean
not innocent in the sense of guilty I
just mean that maybe you have to think
about what exactly it is you're doing
what assumptions you're making and what
you're supposed to learn from this and
that's what we will learn from listening
to what Andrew has to say especially
about you know you might think let's put
it this way you might think that how
hard can it be you take the equations
you take some initial conditions for
your Universe with some matter and some
gravity put it on a computer and solve
the equations how hard can it be it can
be hard it can be subtle because the map
is not the territory the simulation is
not exact you're going to be making
choices along the way about which parts
of the universe are important to
simulate which parts you can kind of
approximate and I think that's the the
thing that Andrew does the best job at
it really uh driving home so this is a
window into a crucially important part
of modern cosmology but also
implicitly a window into how science
gets done in a very general sense so
it's a lot of fun to learn about that
think about it let's go
[Music]
Andrew ponson welcome to mindscape
podcast thank you it's great to be here
we're going to be talking about
simulations right putting things on the
computer putting ideas on the computer
and uh watching them go I I can't help
but tell a funny story right away
because just as we're talking about this
uh there's a little Twitter kerfuffle
because there was a story that came out
that people had done a simulation of
artificial intelligence on the
battlefield
and they said the AI was trained to
score points by killing people and it
there was a human in the loop saying uh
you know don't kill that person don't
kill that person kill this person and in
the simulation the report said the AI
realized that it would score more points
by killing its operators that it would
never be told not to kill people anymore
it turns out that was completely not a
simulation at least not a simulation in
the sense that we're talking about it
was basically these guys thought it up
which which doesn't quite count so
that's an opening so what what counts as
a simulation in this sense well I I you
know I think that's a great question
because uh the book interprets it quite
broadly
um so you know I I think at the heart of
it a simulation is trying to make a
computer
reproduce some kind of phenomenon now
the phenomenon might be in physics so it
might be the way that the Universe
evolves the way that galaxies grow
within it the way that say black holes
Collide and make gravitational waves or
the way that exotic substances like dark
matter and dark energy sculpt our
universe it might be all of those things
or it might be something really very
different so
um in in the book I'm I'm arguing
actually that we can think of things
like artificial intelligence as
simulations
now that they're not they're not
literally simulations of the human brain
they're not kind of trying to uh
reproduce the physiology of what's going
on inside our brains
um apart from anything else that's just
way too complicated to fit on a computer
right now but they're taking kind of
loose inspiration from the way that we
we know that brains do work and they're
taking that loose inspiration and trying
to use it to reproduce something a bit
like thought
right um so so I think that that is a
simulation and I think one of the things
that I really wanted to do with this
book is say that when we do a physics
simulation you might imagine well that's
a much more straightforward thing right
we we know the laws of physics in a way
that we don't know the laws of thought
so so you might imagine okay what you
just take the laws of physics you write
down Einstein's equations you do some
clever maths to fit them on a computer
and you hit go and then you see what
happens
but it's not like that at all
because I mean in some Ideal World we
might imagine we want to do that but we
just cannot because the complexity of
the universe you know it's the the sheer
size of the universe its extent but also
its complexity in the sense of just the
sheer number of elements that are
interacting and the sheer range of
different bits of physics that are are
therefore involved
it means it just that doesn't fit on a
computer you cannot fit the universe
inside a computer
and and therefore even when we're doing
physics simulations there's a ton of
approximations and kind of human
creativity and and leaps of the
imagination that go into even fitting
these things on a computer in the first
place so what is a simulation in my mind
it's something that's
um trying to kind of provide some
guidance to the way the world or the
universe or thought works but it's not
kind of slavishly following
some predetermined set of rules or
anything that there's a lot of
creativity involved in in being able to
try and draw out that story
you did mention that it was on a
computer as opposed to the guy who just
thought something up and called that a
simulation but we have to relate to the
non-astronomers in the audience the
wonderful story of the early Galactic
Dynamic simulation with light bulbs
yes absolutely so it doesn't have to be
on a computer you're absolutely right
and
um I tried to kind of trace the origins
of where did this idea of simulation
come from I mean it dates all the way
back in fact to Ada Lovelace uh who uh
when looking at kind of but before a
computer was ever built just thinking
about the kind of operations a computer
could do
she actually came up with the idea of a
simulation and the idea that it could
try you know starting to reproduce
phenomena in the natural world so it
goes back at least that far possibly I
mean arguably even further than that but
at least that far and and you're right
um that there's there's this amazing
story of of of people who uh tried to do
simulations before computers were
available
um including uh simulations of merging
galaxies so if you imagine that a galaxy
is made up of hundreds of billions of
stars but sometimes two of those
galaxies each with their own hundreds of
billions of stars actually come together
in our universe and and smash together
um and because of the gravity they don't
just kind of pass through each other the
gravity kind of glues them together all
all into one so there was this eccentric
astronomer who tried to reproduce this
in a laboratory before computers were
available using light bulbs so the light
bulbs kind of stood in for stars he
didn't have hundreds of billions of them
obviously that would be that would be
impossible so again it's like a creative
leap instead of having hundreds of
billions of stars I'll just have a few
light bulbs I think he had a around 70
light bulbs or so are we talking uh we
we are talking in I think about the
1940s okay if I remember correctly so
not that not that far off the invention
of the digital computer but
um before it was available certainly
before it was widely available
um and so inside this laboratory you you
kind of black out all other sources of
light and you just have these Shining
Light Bulbs inside the laboratory
and then the kind of Master stroke here
is to realize the strength of the light
coming from each bulb
can be used as a kind of proxy for
gravitational attraction
so because the intensity of light from
from any light source as you move away
it falls off like technically we're
talking about the inverse Square law
here so it falls off in a very
particular way and that turns out that
it falls off in exactly the same way as
a gravitational field falls off so if
you measure the strength of the light
coming from these shining bulbs then
that's like a proxy for the strength of
the gravity
and then you can use that as a kind of
shortcut to calculating gravitational
forces
and and and and and that way you kind of
move the bulbs around in your laboratory
measuring the light all the time and
um it's absolutely amazing paper uh that
results from this showing the merger of
two galaxies uh using this technique
it's something that you could not
calculate by hand if you if you tried to
calculate this by hand you would
literally do a a lifetime of calculating
to get to this answer
did he learn anything from that
experiment that was sort of an
interesting Discovery absolutely yeah I
mean I think it was it was unclear
whether two galaxies would just kind of
run past each other or whether they
would uh merge together if you kind of
set them on some kind of realistic track
uh on on some realistic Collision Course
and and the way that they interact the
way that for example it kind of throws
out uh these things that look like
Spiral arms so often if you look at
galaxies and especially if you look at a
an image of two merging galaxies you'll
find the kind of these big
arms kind of thrown out
um where there's there's more light
along certain directions than others
um it showed how those spiral arms could
be generated through this process now
there are many other ways that you can
generate spiral arms as well but um it
was an early kind of success from a from
well yeah I mean you can call it a
simulation
but yeah that is great I I love the
story it is absolutely ingenious like
you said
um but okay let's just hop to the
present day okay we've passed the light
bulb stage uh nowadays we're testing the
Big Bang model and its scenario for
Galaxy formation and structure and
things like that so maybe I know this is
an Old Chestnut but let's distinguish
between the Big Bang model and the Big
Bang the event at the beginning of the
universe
right I mean I guess that the the Big
Bang model is the idea that our universe
is expanding for one thing
um that is established Beyond any
reasonable doubt that there is just no
reasonable way you could argue that the
Universe isn't expanding so let's deal
with that first
um and it used to be hot right that's a
big part of the Big Bang indeed so if
you extrapolate backwards in time uh
then by the laws of physics because as
you go backwards in time everything is
closer together in the same way that if
you kind of squeeze air into a into a
bicycle tire or something you can feel
things getting hot and so if you imagine
going backwards in time the universe was
not just denser it was also hotter
so uh this this is kind of the Big Bang
model is the idea that uh the universe
started in some kind of very hot dense
State and we have direct evidence for it
being hot as well in the form of the
cosmic microwave background radiation
kind of leftover light from that very
hot uh early phase
um however
if you go back before that even further
the question is what happened uh right
at the start you know if you just keep
going backwards in time the universe is
smaller and smaller and smaller
um if you just sort of extrapolate that
back using Einstein's equations of
general relativity which would seem to
be the right way to extrapolate it back
you get to a moment in time where
everything was at a point
uh the kind of you know infinite density
all the all the mass in the universe
contained in this single point and
that's the kind of classical Big Bang
idea that the Universe actually started
from a point and then something made it
expand outwards and it's been kind of
going ever since
that's the big bang the the moment that
it goes from the point to being an
expanding universe
I think I mean you you'll have your own
take on this but I think most
cosmologists these days would not take
that as a literal account of what
happened at the beginning of our
universe too seriously so it's in some
sense we've sort of moved Beyond
believing in that in in the Big Bang but
we still believe in the Big Bang model
the idea that the Universe was once very
hot and dense and that and that it
started extremely small just the idea
that it actually started at a point I
think has been replaced by other more
sophisticated ideas about what might
have been happening in those very early
moments
and we kind of don't need to know
because what you well for the purposes
that you're interested in working within
the Big Bang model you want to
understand how galaxies and and stars
and structure form right I mean what's
the basic picture there that we're
testing
yeah so the the key for for us is to
understand
what is it that's built the familiar
Universe today so if if you look around
you if you look up into the night sky
what do you see you see individual Stars
um if you're lucky you live somewhere
it's dark enough or you can see a kind
of the the Milky band across the sky
which is the Milky Way if you're really
super lucky and you have a a pair of
binoculars or or so on and you you know
where to look you can find things like
the Andromeda galaxy other galaxies
beyond our own containing their own
hundreds of billions of stars so the
universe today is kind of consisting of
uh lots of individual Stars many of them
perhaps most of them with their own
planets organized in a very particular
way into these kind of islands that we
call galaxies our own is the Milky Way
and then look out far beyond that and
you find other galaxies and if you look
out Way Beyond that and you kind of
somehow get an eagle-eye view of the
universe so that you zoom out so far
that even individual galaxies become
dots
then everything is organized into
something that we call the cosmic web
where the galaxies themselves are not
just scattered through space they line
up in some kind of vasts it almost looks
like a cobweb like structure
so what we're really asking when we do
simulations is is a couple of things how
did that come about
how do our own Origins as a human
species relate to that because there's a
kind of surprising link between all of
that vastness mind-boggling vastness and
our own existence here uh down on rocky
planet Earth
um and and then you know on top of that
I think we're trying to ask
how does the fundamental constituents of
the universe affect what we end up
seeing so that's when we get onto things
like the behavior of stars and black
holes and also onto exotic substances
that we think have to be out there
things like dark matter and dark energy
that we're not seeing directly but that
we think are responsible for sculpting
all this
now to Circle all the way back to where
we started yeah you know with with how
does the Big Bang relate to all of this
well if you want to run a simulation of
anything
then you need to have what we call
Initial conditions and um you know I I
use the weather as a kind of jumping off
point for exactly this reason that I I
think you know you wouldn't expect
anybody to be able to produce you a
weather forecast unless they already
know what the weather's doing today no
if if there's a storm coming in then the
the fact that it's there it's already
there somewhere on planet Earth you need
to know that and then you can use a
simulation to figure out how it's going
to move
well in cosmology we're doing something
very similar we we need some kind of
starting point how do we think the
universe began
in order to work out well what happens
next and what does it all mean
and so the Big Bang on its own is not a
good enough starting point we need
something with more detail we need
something more sophisticated than that
and and that takes you off into the
realm of quantum mechanics you know what
was really going on when the universe
was that small and Cosmic inflation and
exciting ideas like that so those are
kind of inputs into the whole simulation
project
well I I guess let's let's get into the
details here a little bit so I get the
idea that we're starting with some
initial conditions and then letting them
go for forming galaxies do we really
need to talk about Quantum fluctuations
and inflation or can we just say well at
let's say the moment of the cosmic
microwave background being formed right
when we when we see some actual
fluctuations in the sky that gives us
enough information to start our initial
conditions or do we need even more than
that
well the thing about the cosmic
microwave background is it gives us
great evidence for the physical theory
of something like Cosmic inflation
um but it doesn't directly tell you what
the initial conditions for the universe
should be it's like a it's like a
projection so it's like a kind of it
it's we're seeing a frozen
representation of uh what certain parts
of the early Universe were like and it's
frozen because at some point the uh the
the photons can start moving on straight
lines so they're no longer the universe
is not hot enough to have all the
electrons around that are scattering
them and so on so at some point the
light from the early Universe can start
traveling in straight lines and after
that moment it just keeps traveling
until it hits something which if we're
lucky you know it might be one of our
telescopes and so and so and so we get
to see this Frozen moment in our
universe's history but it doesn't tell
you all there is to know to go from that
to a kind of 3D representation of what
do you think the early Universe was
really like
takes quite a lot of physics so you
can't just jump from oh here's the
picture of of the cosmic microwave
background that's what our uh our
simulation should start from you have to
use some smart physics to be able to
connect that up with a theory that gives
you something much more concrete to
start your simulation from
and okay that's that is very helpful
thank you so it's a little bit of a I
don't want to say black magic but a
little bit of art that comes in here
right I mean the whole idea of the these
Cosmic simulations is sounds like a back
and forth between well we think this is
reasonable let's simulate it let's test
it against the data let's go back and
figure out whether our assumptions are
reasonable to start with
it yeah it it's it absolutely is a kind
of uh it's dangerously circular in some
ways so I think you know on on the
initial conditions I don't find that so
worrying precisely because we have such
great measurements of
um of the cosmic microwave background
um I I don't think we're too worried
about the initial conditions being
completely wrong and there's there's
room for them to be refined and you know
you can you can go and test oh well if
my initial conditions are slightly
different uh and and there are reasons
why that might happen for instance if
the flavor of dark matter you have is
slightly different from what we
currently expect that can change those
initial conditions but um the the
we're talking about details there you
know those are relatively small details
in terms of the kind of overall story
that that that simulations paint there
is a much bigger elephant in the room
and and the elephants what's that you
can't just say that yeah yeah yeah the
the elephant in the room is something
that we call uh the subgrid
so it's worth it's worth just pausing to
see what that is I mean earlier on I was
saying there is some creativity involved
in fitting all the physics into a
computer and the subgrid in some sense
is it is a way of talking about that and
and it's called the subgrid because
sometimes you know one way you can do a
simulation is to divide up the universe
or whatever it is you're simulating into
a series of of Cubes like a like a 3D
grid
um but any computer even if we're
working with the world's best
supercomputers we uh still have a finite
number of those cubes that we can fit
inside the computer's memory and and
then you come to the question what
happens inside one of those cubes
and the simple answer is nothing because
the computer can't go any finer than
that that's the whole point of making
the Grid in the first place
but if you if you're happy with that
answer then you're in big trouble so I I
again if you've got if you go back to
the weather it kind of becomes more
tangible so if you imagine you kind of
look up
um and you you look up on a hot humid
day then um you'll start to see kind of
very small uh but but big big tall but
small in terms of the kind of overall
landscape clouds they're starting to
form they're actually forming through a
process called convection it happens on
really quite small scales where there's
a kind of updraft of hot humid air
coming up from the ground uh it
condenses into a cloud up uh at a large
height and then that air cools and
starts to come back down again so that's
a process called convection and it
happens on super small scales way
smaller than any weather forecast can
actually uh resolve in its grid so
that's an example of a subgrid process
and if you just ignore that that then
you're going to miss the vast majority
of thunderstorms that you they're just
not going to happen
and even worse than that even if you
were happy with missing the
thunderstorms the fact that those clouds
are forming
has a what we call a feedback on the
rest of the weather forecasts so if you
have a cloud up in the sky that means
the sun's heat is no longer reaching the
ground
so the temperatures are going to be
different and once the temperatures are
different that's going to generate
different winds and you know before you
know it everything you thought you knew
about the weather forecast is wrong
because you didn't have these kind of
small clouds being generated so what a
weather forecasters do they add them by
hand basically this is what we call the
sub grid they go in and they say well
these things have to form but we can't
get them to form using these sort of
laws of physics that we started with
because they're too small relative to
our grid so we'll just add a rule we'll
make it up we'll say if it's a hot humid
day a certain fraction of our uh our
cubes our um our grid cells they're
going to start to have clouds in them at
a certain rate
and if you're a weather forecaster okay
that's not too much of a travel you can
you can write that down you can write
down a rate at which these clouds are
going to form and you can tune it like
you have plenty of data at your disposal
you can just go and tweak the knobs
until your weather forecasts start being
good you can even kind of calibrate it
on all data you can imagine
go back a week would we have predicted
uh today's weather better if we'd made
some change to our subgrid
so if you're a weather forecaster I
think the idea of the subgrid is quite
natural
as a cosmologist we Face similar
problems so a similar problem for us
would be say the formation of an
individual star
that's actually really hard to see on a
cosmic scale I mean we've already
mentioned right there's hundreds of
billions of stars just in one Galaxy and
then hundreds of billions of galaxies in
the observable universe so the idea that
you would ever see an individual star
form within a simulation it's just not
going to happen there's no supercomputer
on Earth that's powerful enough to do
that but um if we run all our
simulations and they had no stars in
them
then we'd be in trouble right I mean we
wouldn't be simulating the universe so
we have to go in and
Force the Stars to form
and um this is the tip of the iceberg
but it's the kind of thing we're talking
about this is the sub grid and you can
look at it in two ways meaning one is to
say it's exciting you know it's a
different way of thinking about physics
the other which you kind of alluded to a
moment ago is is to say this is
dangerous right because how do we get
this right well the answer is we make it
up we look at the real universe and then
we tweak things until our virtual
universe is start resembling the real
universe so you know in the final
analysis what what are we really doing
and you'd guess I wouldn't be writing
about this if I thought it was actually
a pointless exercise I don't think it is
but but it's definitely complicated it's
uh yeah it's not a straightforward oh
you know we we type in some code and it
reproduces the universe no absolutely
not there's some very subtle things
going on there that you need to be
really on top of if you want to
interpret what people are saying about
their simulations
I do think this is a crucially important
point I want to dwell on it but let me
let's actually back up and set the stage
a little bit because I bet that
there are people out there who think
that this whole subgrid thing is a very
different kind of simulation than they
would have guessed you were doing I mean
maybe the most naive thing following our
friend with the light bulbs would be to
say I'm simulating a bunch of points
representing individual stars or
clusters of stars or things like that
and I'm watching those points move
around in my computer simulation and I
think that what you're saying is that's
just not at all what we're doing we're
dividing space up into cubes and every
Cube might contain the equivalent of
lots of stars and we're trying to figure
out what the effective physics in is per
Cube and how the cubes interact with
each other
yeah I mean I I we're doing something
some slightly in between I suppose those
those two extremes that you just
described so
um we we we can do simulations with
cubes they're not always with cubes
sometimes we're using kind of meshes
that can distort into different shapes
and so on but thinking about it as cubes
is is not a bad bad way to start that's
how we trust that's how we track
something like gas through the universe
so there's a lot of gas out there in the
universe and we track it in pretty much
that way
then
we we do have that one of these subgrid
rules that looks at each individual
grids grid Cube if you like or or
whatever it is that whatever we
decomposed the the virtual Universe into
and it says is is the bit inside here
suitable for forming Stars it doesn't
have the right conditions and and the
right conditions by the way are things
like just really dense gas is is a good
start and funnily enough cold gas is
also a good start there's a camp that
can be a bit of a surprise because of
course stars are hot but to form a star
you first of all need to get the gas to
be really cold just so that it can
collapse down to a small enough scale uh
that it can actually you know start up
at the nuclear fusion processes and so
on so very roughly if the if if there's
a sort of chunk of gas that's cold and
dense then it can start to form Stars
what we do then
is we kind of create what we sometimes
call Star particles
and so so this is then going a little
bit more back to that laboratory setting
where you imagine now okay I've got a
DOT as well as the grid I've also got a
dot in my simulation
and that dot is going to be allowed to
move around it's going to follow it's
going to basically follow the trajectory
determined by
um a gravitational attraction
um and um as it moves around it's going
to pass through a bunch of different uh
cubes
and it can affect the gas around it as
as it moves around
now one thing to keep in mind we are not
talking about one star here we we are
talking about we imagine a kind of whole
collection of stars have formed
and and we're kind of following them as
Representatives almost yeah of the stars
in the universe because again we just
cannot track the individual Stars so we
have a kind of collection of stars
moving through the moving through our
virtual universe and they're doing
things to the gas as they go you know if
you if you study Stars you find out that
they do all sorts of interesting things
in their lives they they spew out gas
through what we call Stellar winds
um they uh have magnetic fields they do
other interesting things like when they
come to the end of their lives they
explode a lot of them do anyway yeah and
and that that puts huge amounts of
energy back into the Galaxy from which
the star formed so we need to capture
all of these things
um and um it can get
um it can get difficult to differentiate
in one's mind you know what should one
think of as kind of the real physics and
and what should we think of as stuff
that we've made up but having clarity
about that I think is the key to really
understanding what simulations are are
actually doing
I remember being impressed and surprised
the first time I learned that even
though there are a lot of stars in a
galaxy individual Supernova events when
a star really blows up actually are
quite important for figuring out the
evolution of the Galaxy as a whole
that's absolutely right and I I think
you know the realization of how
important supernovies are to determining
that the whole future of a galaxy this
has come about not exclusively but but
in large part driven by simulations
themselves so in fact I mean another
another story of you know the origins of
simulations which I really like going
into in the book comes from a character
called Beatrice Tinsley who she she was
actually one of the first people to try
and simulate a Galaxy on a computer and
this was in The Late Late 1960s so by
now we are talking about computers more
or less as we'd recognize them but not
with the kind of the kind of power that
we take for granted these are very very
primitive machines by today's standards
but
she was able to do some of the kind of
physics we're talking about but she she
really stripped the problem back to its
Bare Bones and talk just about the rate
at which stars formed inside a single
Galaxy and trying to understand how is
that determined some of her later work
then started looking at precisely this
thing that an individual Supernova going
off
can change the future of a galaxy
because it goes off it it pumps a load
of energy into the gas that heats up the
gas and when you heat up gas it can even
get expelled from the Galaxy that's one
possibility but certainly it tends to
stop it from forming further stars
because as I was saying earlier gas
needs to be cold to form Stars so the
fate of the Galaxy is bound up in the
supernovae going off and and when she
realized this actually it had a profound
effect on all of cosmology because it it
revealed that you can't think of
galaxies as these kind of passive things
that just sit there kind of being boring
lights for the universe as a whole which
actually a lot of cosmologists thought
about it that way and and one of the
things that that changed overnight
almost was the idea that the universe as
a whole was going to collapse in on
itself and at the end we've spoken a bit
about the beginning of the universe
there was this idea in the in the late
1960s that the whole universe would
recollapse and you'd have something
called the Big Crunch
well that came about from trying to map
out how the universe was expanding today
it was using the galaxies to do that as
though they were just these kind of
inanimate things that just sat there and
didn't really have an internal life
the moment that you added this kind of
internal life to galaxies you had to
reinterpret all the observations you
were taking and and and it kind of led
to a complete Paradigm Shift where uh no
longer did the observational evidence
say that the Universe was going to
recollapse and that paved the way of
course for for our modern understanding
which is that the universe is probably
going to expand forever and and do so at
a accelerating rate so I mean they
couldn't have been more wrong and and it
all comes back to how how you regard
supernovae which you know it yeah it
seems like it it seems so disconnected
like these quite esoteric concerns about
how a Galaxy evolves changes the fate of
the entire universe and and and I really
you know I I really love tracing the
origin of these ideas
well that brings us right to another
thing I want to get to which is again
backing up a little bit from where we
are now because when I was a grad
student uh I think that the idea of
using gas Dynamics and hydrodynamics and
adaptive meshes and things like that
these were all brand new ideas right
this was not there was still a lot of
simulations going on but they were
basically just gravity and dark matter
and so those are still very important
why don't we talk a little bit about
gravity and dark matter I mean how did
we get from the tiny fluctuations at the
CMB era when the micro background was
formed to the first stars and galaxies
yup you are absolutely right that you
know what you see in the cosmic
microwave background is just small
differences from one part of the
universe to another
whereas when we're talking about
galaxies and the cosmic web that I
mentioned earlier these are huge huge
differences that you know if if you
lived today in a completely randomly
chosen part of the universe it would
your experience would not at all be like
our experience I mean first of all you
wouldn't be on a planet so so let's just
put that to one side imagine you've got
a spacesuit and you teleport to a
completely random part of the universe
well when you did that the the density
around you is going to be almost nil and
not only that but you won't be able to
see any stars because a typical Galaxy
will be a very long way away from you
and so if you teleport to a random part
of the universe today it's completely
different from the part of the universe
we live in whereas in those Early times
the universe was much the same
everywhere you know in in the cosmic
microwave background the differences
we're talking about are what like one
part in a hundred thousand very very
tiny tiny differences from one place to
another
um whereas now we're talking about
contrasts of you know
millions billions easily you know these
are the kind of contrasts that we're
talking about today rather than these
very gentle ripples now something has to
power that something has to build all of
that structure and I think
one of the most underappreciated pieces
of evidence for dark matter
is exactly that structure formation
process so you know if you for anybody
who hasn't come across it before dark
matter is this extra stuff that we think
has to be in the universe uh that we
can't see directly
but that uh we think is there because of
its gravitational effects and very often
when you hear this explained you'll hear
somebody say it's to do it the way that
galaxies rotate or something like that
right so if you look at the the way a
galaxy is rotating you find that the
stars in its outer parts are moving so
fast that if you just add up all the
Gravity from the things you see so the
other stars and the and the gas and so
on that is not enough gravity to keep it
connected to the rest of the Galaxy it's
moving so fast it should just kind of
fly off like a like a car that's just
kind of cornered and didn't didn't have
enough grip and it just kind of flew off
the track and and now it's somewhere
else so those Stars should be lost
that's the kind of classic evidence
people give for dark matter
now
it that that's been criticized for being
relatively weak there are it's a kind of
relatively weak argument you can find
ways to get around it
but I think you know the really
compelling evidence for dark matter is
when you can trust something like the
cosmic microwave background
um and the universe today because
something had to build all of these
structures and that takes a huge amount
of force just to move everything far
enough to build these kind of structures
out of the early universe and the only
way you can really make sense of having
that Force available to you is if there
is a huge amount of extra stuff in other
words dark matter that is is pulling
gravitationally but that otherwise is
remarkably elusive that we we can't see
it directly we don't kind of feel it
directly even though it's kind of
passing through us here on Earth
um
um that line of evidence to my mind uh
when you kind of put all of these things
together is the strongest line of
evidence for Dark Matter actually being
a real thing
but of course what we want to do is
compare that idea with something like
modifying gravity right do you do you
and the people you hang out with doing
these simulations take modified gravity
seriously as an alternative to dark
matter
well yeah I mean we we do uh however we
don't work on it ourselves so so the
peop so most people working in
simulations right now are working within
the Dark Matter uh Paradigm and the
reason for that is pretty
straightforward it's been a very
predictive Paradigm so that what I'm
talking about about this structure
formation process is not something that
was used to kind of
as as a kind of starting point and then
we go oh what do we need and then we
kind of make up Dark Matter it wasn't
that way around so if you look at
something like the cosmic microwave
background even the particular ripples
you see in the cosmic microwave
background and then the way that those
grow
all of those things are predictions from
the Dark Matter Paradigm where the Dark
Matter Paradigm really grew up in the
1980s I guess and and during that time a
kind of combination of some theoretical
calculations and some early simulations
really started to make clear just how
powerful it could be but it started from
the Dark Matter hypothesis which had
been invented it was motivated by the
kind of things like the spin of galaxies
and so on and then it came to the kind
of predictions for the cosmic microwave
background and predictions for what the
structure of the universe looked like
um so it is a remarkably predictive
paradigm
and to me that makes it a very
attractive thing to work on I think if
you contrast that with modified gravity
modify gravity has not been predicted it
has tried to explain things it's tried
to say well instead of having
extra material to generate that extra
gravity what if you just change the laws
of gravity themselves
um and you know certain observations it
can explain pretty well in that way but
it is never
made a prediction that has has turned
out to be accurate and for that reason
um it's just to my mind it's not an
attractive thing to work on and I think
a lot of simulators feel the same way
about it it doesn't mean it's wrong
right I I'm always at pains to point
this out we are not saying dark matter
is right and modified gravity is wrong
we're saying we have finite resources we
have finite time we need to choose what
to work on this seems like a better line
of inquiry
until we actually find dark matter in
the lab we can't be sure we're right
um but it just it just seems more
promising
such a responsible scientific attitude
that you have I don't know if you're
going to get very far in this world like
that in the public relations world but
good I mean I'm 100 on your side about
this but let me just play one little bit
of Devil's Advocate here if if we had an
advocate of Mond of modified Newtonian
Dynamics right uh Milgram or one of his
uh the people who think that he's on the
right track I think what they would say
is sure we don't have a full Theory we
don't make all the predictions but what
we do have is an explanation for the
particular features and the
phenomenology of galaxies you know where
the dark matter is in galaxies how the
rotation curves look the you know the
the uh the implied amount of mass that
you get Etc so do you does the Dark
Matter traditional Paradigm is it able
to explain those features yet or is that
just something where we say well someday
it will be but we're not quite there yet
yeah so I think I let me answer in two
parts so I think they they would make
exactly that point
um however if you look at the way that
the observations are treated by the
modified gravity community and now
perhaps I'm getting into more
controversial territory but I mean I
think the the risk is that they tend to
focus on particular observations uh
rather than try to explain the kind of
full gamut of observations that we
actually have available to us now that's
a dangerous game to play you know
arguably you have to play that game
sometimes because you have to focus your
work in just the same way that I was
talking about a moment ago but I think
that there are there are many
observations that modify gravity really
struggles with
as well as some observations that it
makes some sense of and and that's true
even in the Galaxy's world right so even
if you
um accept that you're going to focus on
Galaxies even then there are a ton of
observations which modify gravity really
struggles to explain
so
um
I I think for me that's an an important
Point
um as to does Dark Matter explain the
same set of things that modified gravity
can explain I mean to first order to A
first order approximation yes it does
um so it's certainly explains for
example the the overall kind of shape of
uh Galaxy rotation curves for instance
this is a big a big thing you know you
measure how quickly is a Galaxy rotating
as a function of radius
Dark Matter does a good job of of
explaining that
however there there is a criticism that
in Dark Matter this is a kind of
emergent phenomenon the the the the the
way the particular way a Galaxy rotates
is something that emerges from the
underlying Theory rather than something
that you predict from directly from the
theory itself you need to run
simulations to be able to make that
prediction really with with cold Dark
Matter so the so so it's not necessarily
quite so clear a priori why called Dark
Matter produces the kind of rotation
curves that it does
um so so I think you know there is an
argument to be had around that and I
think another thing that the modified
gravity Community might say is it's it's
also unclear why there's so little
scatter on some of these observations
that in modified gravity every Galaxy
essentially should behave roughly in the
same way with respect to its um rotation
rotation whereas with dark matter
because the amount of dark matter can be
different
um
especially you know how how it is
distributed through a Galaxy can be
different from one galaxy to another
you're left sort of having to explain
well then why is it that all the
galaxies sort of seem to have such
similar phenomenology
um why is there not more variation
and I think that's an interesting to
interesting discussion to to have I
think we can explain that I think it
comes back to the kind of feedback
things that we were talking about about
the way that uh you know we were talking
about specifically about supernovae but
that's not the only one there are many
feedback relationships where a Galaxy if
it has too many stars for example then
uh it's going to start having lots of
supernovae that's going to expel gas and
that means it's not going to form as
many stars in the future there are other
feedback mechanisms in addition to that
relating for instance to black holes we
we know that there are supermassive
black holes at the center of most
perhaps all all galaxies and um and they
also have a feedback relationship with
the Galaxy and the Dark Matter around
them so I think the answer probably lies
in those feedback relationships but I
think it would be a fair criticism to
say that's not fully understood at this
point of in time but I would just go
back to say saying you know that is in
within the context of a theory that has
been incredibly predictive on a huge
range of scales ranging from the entire
universe down to Tiny uh little what we
call dwarf galaxies so so to my mind uh
it's it's it's an interesting question
but it's not the kind of thing that
convinces me to go and work on modify
gravity
it's an audio podcast so the audience
doesn't know but I've been nodding along
for everything you've been saying here I
think that this is very much on the
right track but I should bring up the
other uh worry that has peaked into our
Consciousness about the whole
um hot big bang gravitational
instability leading to Galaxy's story
which is uh observations from the James
Webb Space Telescope this is I'm
contractually obligated to say this
because my office at Johns Hopkins is
across the street from the Space
Telescope Science Institute so if I can
bring up jwst I have to do it and uh
it's a powerful new telescope that has
apparently found very early galaxies
galaxies that are far away and therefore
early in the history of the universe
that are very massive that that we would
have thought would have taken longer
time to assemble so is this considered a
challenge is something that you can
account for or is this something where
you think those observations are
probably a little sloppy because it's
the early days and hopefully they will
go away
well I mean yeah this this is something
we could talk about for a whole hour I
think because this is this is you know
really exciting cutting-edge stuff and I
think the answer in brief is a
combination of all the things you just
mentioned right so first thing to say is
jwst has just kind of been performing
Beyond people's wildest dreams right I
mean it is such a fantastic new
telescope bringing the bringing the
cosmos to to in into into our uh our own
our own homes right the pictures that
we're getting to see from it
um and uh reaching out much further to
see the story of Galaxy formation much
further than has been possible in the
past so the first thing I wanted to to
say in response to that is just how
exciting it is to to be living through
this time where the first observations
come from from jwst but let's just
rewind for a moment let's imagine the
Hubble Space Telescope launch now I was
I was young when the Hubble Space
Telescope launched I just about remember
the the excitement around it um I would
have been at school I remember it being
on the news because it had the faulty
Optics which then got got fixed um by by
an astronaut spacewalk and and then it
started taking just fantastic pictures
um so this would have been what 93 94 is
that that kind of um
um and you know one of the things one of
the early pictures it took was something
called the Hubble Deep Field
so the the plan here was to point Hubble
for I think around a week or so at a
patch of the sky that had was was not
known to contain anything just nothing
of of any interest
sounds a little crazy but the idea was
build up sensitivity by by pointing this
incredible new telescope at just one
patch of the sky for that kind of very
extended period and see what's there
and what was you know after that had
taken place and it was beamed back and
and and and people recreated the picture
we got a kind of iconic picture of a
kind of a a empty space with a whole
series of dots and swirls in it and
basically everything that you see in
that picture and you can easily go and
see it today right you've just Google
this thing
um is everything that you see is a
Galaxy that's far far away and
um this was an incredible New View at
the time of the way what was then
thought to be the early Universe uh was
was evolving
and it was a catastrophe for simulators
a total catastrophe because the kind of
um predictions that had been made such
as they were were that if you did an
exercise like this it would actually be
full of quite bright large galaxies that
this was despite the fact that people
knew about the way that the the universe
had been uh a building building up its
galaxies through the gravitational
effects of dark matter all the things
that we talked about you know the Bare
Bones of that were known at the time
but the simulations were just getting
the details wrong and the details of
feedback we keep coming back to it this
this this sub grid and the way you you
the way you calibrate that and get all
of those details right about when do
stars form how do they form do they form
clumped together or in kind of spread
out and all of these kind of things
really matter to be able to go from the
bare bones of the scenario you're
talking about
to the kind of detail of what will you
see with a particular telescope so that
leap that took place in the mid 90s
um it was on the face of it really
catastrophic for um for the Dark Matter
Paradigm because the predictions that
had been made were way off
but but very quickly people realized
what that was telling them it was it was
telling them that they hadn't been
um they hadn't been treating the way
that stars formed correctly this needed
to be Revisited and a lot was learned
through that process
um and I suspect what we're seeing with
James Webb is some a very similar
process beginning where it's going to
tell us stuff we are going to learn new
stuff about the Way galaxies form
but it's it's very premature to jump to
any kind of headline that says this puts
the overall story in jeopardy
um got it it doesn't it it it it throws
up interesting challenges but as things
stand it doesn't put the overall story
in Jeopardy and probably some some
combination of improving the simulations
and
um
refining uh the way we treat this data
from telescopes getting getting getting
better data from uh jwst and in
particular getting more Spectra that's
where the light from these galaxies is
broken down into its different component
colors so all of these things I think
are going to get to a much more measured
consensus at some point
now if the challenges seem
insurmountable in a couple of years from
now then we might be having a very
different discussion but when you have a
new technology like this it just takes
time to integrate what it's showing us
and and I think I I just say one more
thing on this which is
this is obviously treading quite a
delicate fine line because on the one
hand hopefully what I'm saying is
reasonable on the other you might be
thinking well hang on a second this
isn't how science is supposed to work
you don't get to revise you don't get to
revise your predictions after you've
taken the data because you went oh well
come on it was complicated you know we
didn't know so I I think we have to be
very aware of treading that fine line
um
there's no getting away from it though
the universe is a complicated messy
place that we cannot fit inside
computers
the way to test our understanding is not
by
um building a a telescope like jwst that
takes us into totally new Realms that
pushes forwards our understanding to a
new level and so it's incredibly
important but the way to test our
understanding is rather more subtle and
it involves kind of finding okay if we
if we're predicting something about how
galaxies form can we find a kind of
Corolla a more direct corollary of that
that we can go and test
this is the kind of thing that we try to
do
um where so for example you know we
think something like our Milky Way
galaxy was built out of lots of tiny
little chunks that would individually
have been very um very dim but they they
have to be out there
um and so if we look if we look back
into the distant Universe we can start
looking for those little chunks of
galaxies things like that which are kind
of direct corollaries from the um from
the picture that we're painting can be
used as tests
um something like this kind of major
step into a whole different Epoch of the
universe's history is much harder to use
as a test and I think you have to expect
there will be some tweaking to what
we're doing and and let's see where we
are like I say in a couple of years
okay so is it fair to say the short
version is these are important results
so we should be pay close attention to
and be open-minded and willing to change
our views if necessary but right now no
reason to really worry about the overall
validity of the Big Bang model
correct yeah right now there's nothing
that would really throw that into doubt
I think though there could be you know
if if some of these things persist and
we persist in in not being able to
explain how such big things came about
and so on so I mean it's not that there
cannot be anything that would make us
start doubting the picture that we're
painting but right now we're just not
there yet
I found a great article online about
this this issue of the early galaxies uh
by Evo lob I don't know if I'm
pronouncing his name correctly but he's
an astronomer and his way of putting it
is that you know the most natural way of
thinking about this is it's not
necessarily
something that these massive galaxies at
Early Times exist but are rare that that
what we're missing here is not a major
feature of our picture of Galaxy
formation but that there's a fast track
for the one percent uh that if you're
really in the right place at the right
time you can make a more massive Galaxy
than we would have expected
that's absolutely right I mean that
could be part of the story so that that
then starts to come down to you know
what data is available so far from
something like uh so something like jwst
and of course inevitably because it's
only been up for for a short while
um it just doesn't have a kind of
Representative survey of of what the
universe really looked like at these
Early Times
um so that will also come and that could
play a part in explaining what's what's
going on here I mean it's it that it's
super interesting because it could also
connect to with the origins of
supermassive black holes so this is the
very massive black holes that we find at
the center of modern galaxies I think
one of the big question marks for Galaxy
formation as a field is where did those
supermassive black holes actually come
from because it's actually very hard to
figure out how do you grow black holes
quickly enough if you imagine just
creating
what we would call a small Stellar Mass
black hole so I mean this is something
that would be a few times the mass of
our sun so it is huge but but small by
comparison to these supermassive black
holes that are millions or even billions
of times the um the the the the mass of
our sun
so how do you get from from one to the
other how do you start from small black
holes and get these absolutely huge
million or billions of times larger
black holes by the present day I mean we
have ideas but that's a very hard thing
to do and it may be that all of these
stories are kind of bound up together in
some way which is going to make the next
you know 10 15 years very exciting
because we have you know a new
gravitational wave facilities uh on on
the horizon on that kind of time scale
where so we'll not only be able to see
what's happening to galaxies at very
early times in our universe well in some
sense also be able to feel what's
happening to galaxies at very early
times in our universe with these very
sensitive
um gravitational wave detectors that
will be able to feel the gravitational
waves coming from the the early
population of black holes so so I think
you know the the the long term for all
of the these questions is going to be
one of piecing together evidence from
many different lines and seeing how we
can get it to hang together rather than
any single uh piece of evidence being
definitive
and I think that maybe there's a
question lingering in people's minds
here like why is it a question how the
black holes form aren't you simulating
what happens shouldn't you see them form
and I take it that this goes back to
that subgrid problem
it goes exactly back to the subgroup
problem so if if you imagine where does
a black hole come from well a a what we
call a stellar Mass black hole is formed
at the end of a life of a star so if we
can't actually be sure about how stars
form then we can't actually be sure
about how black holes form and it gets
even worse than that actually with black
holes because black holes you know the
famous thing about them is anything that
falls into a black hole stays in a black
hole okay well hooking radiation's on
but that's all that's like a much a much
longer term thing when you start talking
about Hawking radiation so you know so
the the main thing about a black hole on
on the kind of uh typical time scales
we're talking about is anything that
goes in stays in
and that means that a black hole can
grow
so it's not just that you form a black
hole and it stays that size it actually
grows over time by kind of eating its
surroundings and yet again we're talking
about the subgrid because you you can't
actually see an individual black hole in
its surroundings you have to make some
informed speculations about how fast
could it eat gas from The Big Cube that
it's sitting inside
and not only that but then that
generates energy that process of eating
the gas what happens to that energy how
does that interact with the gas that
might otherwise have been eaten I mean
maybe the the energy from from eating
one bit of gas can blow away other gas I
mean it becomes
extraordinarily complicated and all of
this has to be handled in some sensible
way
um but yeah you you can't sort of just
zoom in to a simulation and just see
this happening
I guess I'll be remiss in the modern era
if I didn't ask whether there was room
here for AI and uh deep learning models
to help us with some of these questions
I mean people are definitely looking
down those lines the the exact way that
we use deep learning and AI in astronomy
and cosmology is evolving incredibly
fast right now
um and and I think you know one thing
you can imagine doing is you can you can
run a very detailed simulation of how
does a black hole eat some gas now you
if you want to run that detailed
simulation using all of the physics that
you think is relevant then you can't
simulate the rest of the universe right
that's that's a part of the problem but
if you if if you want to you can take
you know your computer time and use it
to do that now so a possible thing you
could do is is subject a black hole to
lots of different conditions and then
get a deep learning model or something
like that to try and predict based on
you can can be trained on those detailed
simulations you run and then you can try
and use that to predict what a black
hole does I mean in in some sense you
know it's not that different from what
we're doing already
that what would the machine learning
learn well it would learn some kind of
set of approximations to what a black
hole is supposed to do
that that's what we're trying to do as
humans and then we're coding those in
into our subgrid so it's it's it's it's
it's a way that you can perhaps kind of
digest more information and uh and and
bring that into the simulation and it's
definitely something that people are
investigating you know with with a lot
of energy but to my mind you know the
real excitement in AI is somewhere
slightly different
so to to my mind you know first of all
AI to my mind is a simulation so that's
why I end up talking about it in the
book it is a simulation of thought
but what we have right now in the AI
landscape is we have things like chat
GPT say which you can go and ask it a
factual question and if you're lucky
it'll give you a factual answer or if
you're unlucky it's gonna it just makes
something up but you know it's it's it's
it's impressive but it it's kind of got
a fairly fixed Corpus of knowledge
that's one that's one kind of segment if
you like and then on another part of the
the AI landscape you you have the kind
of things I was just talking about where
you train models to do quite specific
tasks like predict what should a black
hole do within a Galaxy or something
like that
now the question is how do you start
bringing those things together
how do you start getting AIS that not
only make predictions but explain those
predictions and and even more than that
they don't just explain them they link
them to the existing body of knowledge
so imagine for a moment you had a future
AI that somehow it not it didn't just
study your black hole simulations and
make predictions that you could use
elsewhere it actually explained what
it's learned from those simulations and
started talking to you like a physicist
well now you'd be somewhere very
interesting possibly somewhere
frightening I mean maybe we're going to
be
going to be putting ourselves out of a
job but I I think you know you you can
you can go towards that goal
um right now you can start making steps
towards that goal and I think that's an
incredibly exciting area to to to be
working in we're trying to do that with
respect to you know the overall
formation of structure in the universe
because right now you know our
explanations for how structures
structures form in the universe tend to
consist of saying well you have the laws
of gravity and you have dark matter and
then you program him into a computer and
you hit go and here's what you get
um and if you could if you could start
building on that and actually creating
explanations for why
I mean to go all the way back to to your
question about you know why does
regularity emerge in galaxies that makes
it look like modified gravity
could we start using AIS to to help shed
light in that area
I mean I think maybe we could but it's a
it's difficult because it's having to
bring together these rather different
takes on on AI into a kind of common
framework
I'm remembering now only just now that
we're having this conversation that I
gave I was invited to give a talk at an
APS meeting back in 2006 so ancient
history now on the future of theoretical
cosmology and I remember making
um somewhat tongue-in-cheek predictions
for you know when computers would start
replacing graduate students post-docs
professors but I forget I I've lost my
uh track of exactly what those
predictions were so I think I'm safe I
hope hopefully it was not recorded but
you know never a hundred percent I think
but maybe a lot of the
Dirty Work that we do as theoretical
physicists will be able to be offloaded
to our computer friends
I think that's I think that's possible
and I I think you know
we we have to tread with care here I
mean it it's clear that we are entering
dangerous territory with AI as a whole
and it throws up a bunch of ethical uh
and practical uh dilemmas that that we
have to look at very carefully as as we
do this you know even as physicists it's
not like
um we are trying to develop models that
are going to completely change the world
but we are contributing to that overall
landscape of AI and so I think we we do
have to take a kind of responsible
attitude towards this
um but but yes I think that there is a
role to be played you know it would be
it would be crazy to try and shut
ourselves off from this there is a role
to be played where it can augment rather
than replace what we're doing and the
more we can get it to
um
actually link what it's doing to a a
broader landscape of knowledge I think
the more powerful it's going to become
in in in those regards so
um I'm kind of excited I I guess like
everybody I'm a little scared too
um but I I do think there are exciting
times ahead and I'm kind of an optimist
I I feel like
um I feel like we can do this uh and we
can do it in a way that doesn't
contribute to the downfall of
civilization
that would be good I think that all all
things equal that would be good anyway I
mean maybe the the place to wrap up is
some very big picture philosophical
questions about what's going on here
um when when we talk about simulations I
remember having arguments in graduate
school about this do you count
simulations as part of theory or part of
experiment
right well I mean I I'm on the fence I
think if you look at an individual
simulation you can often locate it in
that Spectrum but I think what's so
interesting about simulations in a sense
is is that they that they they they
definitely span that divide so I can
give you like a couple of extreme
examples I suppose so let's imagine uh
that you uh are uh you're you're working
at the Large Hadron Collider let's say
and you are trying to interpret the data
that you're seeing from the Large Hadron
Collider let's go back in time and
imagine we're trying to pick out the
Higgs boson at the Large Hadron Collider
now there's a there's a big problem with
doing that which is just that the the
Large Hadron Collider does not have a
Higgs boson detector right you you don't
have a detector that actually detects
the Higgs boson directly that cannot be
built what you actually detect at the
Large Hadron Collider is a bunch of
remnants of a Higgs boson after the
Higgs boson has kind of come into
existence momentarily and then uh uh
decayed into a bunch of other particles
those are the things that you actually
detect
so you need simulations actually to
figure out what do we expect to see if
if the Higgs boson is there what do you
expect to see in your detectors it's not
a straightforward thing
so those simulations exist they're run
they're they are a you know a big part
of some people's lives running these
kind of simulations
um so what what is that well I don't I I
personally think that that is uh it's
not an experiment right the simulation
itself is not an experiment it's being
used to interpret an experiment
um and so I it's a calculation I guess
you know it's a calculation of of what
happens under these circumstances it's
not real I wouldn't really call it
Theory because it's it's not uncovering
anything that we fundamentally didn't
know before
so to me therefore that's not really
Theory it's not really experiment it's
more like a calculation so some
simulations are like that they're
calculations there's nothing wrong with
doing calculations right that's that's
at the heart of what of course
physicists
um I think it's Theory I think it's just
100 Theory I mean doing calculations is
Theory yeah I I I think experiment is
collecting data about the physical world
um okay of course when you look at your
computer screen you're collecting data
about the physical world and some very
thin sense like there's a screen in
front of me but the uh I think that the
we should think of I don't care that
much if people want to disagree with
this but I think that simulations are
just tools for being better theorists
for making predictions on the basis of
our theories okay so let me let me let
me try arguing back against that so I I
think you know okay that's arguable for
the case of the the Higgs bows and we
just discussed did you do you call it a
calculation do you call it Theory okay
well it's your potato potato it's kind
of semantics right yeah however I think
there is an argument to be made that in
certain circumstances not the one I just
described but in some circumstances
their experiments simulations are
experiments and uh I I I guess this is
arguing pretty directly against what you
just said but imagine imagine that you
uh haven't discovered the laws of
thermodynamics yet okay and now I give
you a simulation of a large number of
particles and by the way I actually do
this with undergrad classes so in a
sense they haven't discovered all of
thermodynamics yet so it's kind of you
know it's not that counter factual right
so so you you have a simulation it
models roughly what particles do now it
doesn't get every aspect of it 100 like
reality of course it doesn't it just
imagines particles as little bouncy
balls bouncing around
but you can discover
thermodynamics in in these simulations
you can compress the Box the simulation
box you can kind of apply an external
Force compress it and see the things
speed up in other words you're
discovering
um the conservation of energy or you're
discovering that The Interchange between
the external forces and the internal
energy you can do other things you can
discover the the way that substance is
diffuse through a room uh you can
discover Brownian motion you can
discover all sorts of things inside a
simulation now what is the nature of
that Discovery that's that that I guess
is at the heart of it right but to to me
there is not such an obvious fundamental
distinction between what you're
discovering there which is like a kind
of emergent property of the way things
can behave under some circumstances and
what you could discover in a laboratory
setting
I I think that you know the counter
argument is oh well hang on you know the
laboratory that's real physics right but
the computer is just doing what you've
programmed in but but again you know it
that distinction kind of crumbles in
your hands if if you really try to make
it now take another example like um say
I'm I'm I'm working for an airplane
manufacturer I want to know how is my
aircraft Wing going to perform
I can I can make a scale model of it and
put it in a wind tunnel that's an
experiment I'm sure you agree
or I can make a digital version of it
and put it in a virtual environment
um now why is the latter not an
experiment
I mean it's got some approximations in
it that's for sure but then so does the
wind tunnel the wind tunnel has
approximations it's perhaps scaled down
it has a particular type of flow it has
walls which is not going to be which are
not going to be there when you fly your
actual aircraft so
so I I I've always found that the more
you try to examine the more you try to
say you know simulations cannot be
experiments
the more you question well if if that's
true then what is what is an experiment
if a simulation can't be one of them
I think that the answer is that the
experiment tells you something about
what nature does not something about
what your theory predicts now if your
theory is right that also happens to
tell you something about what nature
does like if you do a simulation of
little gas molecules Etc but the point
about that simulation of gas molecules
is that you might discover the laws of
thermodynamics but then you might go out
and look at the world and find that the
world doesn't act that way and you can't
do that without collecting real data
yeah but I I don't know I mean
experiments are rather like that as well
right I mean you you might you have to
make some kind of controlled conditions
you make a bunch of assumptions in how
you set up the experiment what you think
are the relevant things to control so so
that you know experiments are Laden with
Theory at some level you you have to
decide what are you doing what are you
controlling what are you measuring what
do you have to control for all of these
things depend on Theory and then yeah
you might go out into the real world and
find hey whatever I based on that
experiment doesn't appear to be true I I
think honestly the same thing is going
on in simulations and I mean the
thermodynamics example I give it
precisely because it it isn't right
right it's not doing Quantum field
Theory to figure out what the particles
really do it's based on a very naive
idea about what the micro physics world
might look like
and yet
the the macro physics that emerges the
laws of thermodynamics that emerge from
that are empirically correct
um so for emergent phenomena I feel like
simulations you can regard them as
experiments you have to be aware of the
limitations but then you have to be
aware of the limitations of an
experiment as well right so
it it it's it's just it's not obvious to
me how you draw that line
well that is that is perfectly Fair
that's not obvious and and that's why
it's an interesting question but okay
final question then as a simulator of
universes literally
can you imagine a day when you or your
successors are going to simulate people
in your universes and that's going to
lead us to an obvious next question that
I will let you fill in
right yeah so um a short answer is no I
I think as a simulator of universes we
have zero motivation to simulate people
inside those universes just zero I just
cannot imagine why would you want to do
that
um and maybe we can Circle back to that
but just to to flesh out you know you
were saying the next question is obvious
and indeed yeah I mean do do we
ourselves live inside a simulation and
and this is a discussion that's been
been kind of ongoing for many years now
um based on on a number of people's
thinking but I guess Nick Bostrom I
think was on your podcast some time ago
in fact and and Nick Bostrom kind of
distilled this down I think um to to a a
very neat set of ideas so he he sort of
set out a series of postulates one of
them being we're going to want to
continue running simulations that get
ever more detailed
um and sort of if you follow these
postulates it is a logical conclusion
that we ourselves quite possibly live
inside a simulated universe
um so I I have no
um argument against nick bostrom's uh
kind of logic I think the logic is fine
however I think uh where this Falls over
is first of all in assuming well Nick
Bostrom doesn't assume but some people
when they're describing it do assume
that we are going to want to make ever
more more and more detailed simulations
so I think that assumption is probably
incorrect
um as I was just saying
um so so I think you know once once that
assumption is swept away then we no
longer have the simulation hypothesis
looking as strong
um I think there's also a second
you know there's there's a second sort
of practical layer to this that if you
wanted to simulate the universe
perfectly
then you can count the number of bits or
more technically qubits that's required
to do that it's a stupendously large
number it's something like uh 10 to the
124 I think
um that's what's required to simulate
the whole universe and how can you do
that well it turns out that you would
need to use the whole universe to build
your computer because if the whole
universe takes 10 to the 124 qubits to
describe then that's what that though
you need to use all of those qubits to
describe a universe so it becomes
circular right I mean you can't you
can't do a perfect simulation of the
Universe from within the universe itself
so then you can say well maybe the you
know the simulation doesn't have to be
perfect and so on and that leads you
down various routes and you can start
arguing about what would what what are
we really imagining these future
simulators are doing you know why are
they making this simulation that seems
to be so incredibly detailed and stands
up to all of these tests
but but where where in reality it's a
sort of hoax of of some sort and that's
that's where you end up with the
simulation hypothesis it's a basically
conspiracy theory territory and so it's
deeply uncomfortable for that reason but
I I think it obviously just because
something's uncomfortable doesn't mean
it's wrong but I but I think
to my mind the way out of this is to
recognize it's not at all obvious that
you want to carry on running simulations
and and and have a more detailed
simulations
but at least for a little while you're
going to keep wanting to run more
detailed simulations than you have right
now
absolutely yeah for a while you want to
you want to add layers of detail
um but there's another interesting you
know angle on this which is as you add
more detail the simulation gets more
powerful in certain ways but in other
ways it gets less powerful this is the
kind there's a kind of paradox in the
heart of this which is that one of the
ways we really learn from simulations is
to do counterfactual things so an
example would be let's simulate the
universe but let's stop all the black
holes from forming or growing
and let's see what happens
and and we can do that exercise and the
answer is you get galaxies that look
completely wrong so so it reveals a
really deep interplay between the lives
of galaxies and the lies of black holes
which is which is really exciting and
and connects to the things we were
talking about with jwst and future
gravitational wave observatories and so
on that ability to go in and just switch
something off
is tied to the fact the very fact that
our simulations are so crude
you know if the simulation just did
everything all by itself
then there wouldn't be a like a switch
in our code where we could just switch
black holes off because they are an
inevitable consequence of general
relativity so you you wouldn't be able
to do that and and so this is an example
of what I mean when I say there's a
there's a paradox where as you make
simulations more powerful
in some sense they become less powerful
at the same time and and that's why I
don't personally think you just want to
go on adding more and more and more and
more detail to simulations they they
will get more sophisticated over time
but I think there is some point at which
you go you know what we just we're going
to do better simulations and cleverer
simulations but they're not going to
just have more and more layers of detail
okay that's a very actually a very
interesting point but I'm looking
forward to what happens next with even
better simulations and comparing them
with even better data so Andrew ponson
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast
thank you
[Music]
wow